you know it's get back to work week here
on good day las vegas all week long
we're profiling local organizations that
can help you
find a job in the valley a lot of
companies are hiring right now
hector mejia live this morning over at
the goodwill career center at the
boulevard mall with some details hecker
good morning to you
hey there good morning and what's so
cool is that they offer a whole range of
services free of charge so let's say for
example you need a computer you need
internet access and you also need a
place
to make some copies of your resume well
this is one place where you can go to
we're at goodwill of southern nevada the
center over at the boulevard mall
and this is just one of the half a dozen
computers they have available for people
to check out and here we just have their
uh screen here showing the listings of
jobs that are available
here specifically for example box truck
driver
or a clearance center merchandise
processor a whole range of jobs in fact
we'll talk a little bit more about a job
fair coming up in a few minutes but
joining us live we have karen
good morning to you thanks for having us
so early in the morning welcome hector
it's good to have you here
thanks for having us so what are you
holding in your hand we were talking
about what
we're talking about resumes and the
importance of doing a great resume to
just get your foot in the door for a new
employment opportunity
and what we help here at goodwill is
with certified resume writers on staff
we can help customize the resume for the
job that the um that the job seeker is
looking for
all right so for everyone at home
watching wondering what are some
mistakes that people commonly make and
we should look out for
yeah so some simple ones like
proofreading and
making sure that everything is spelled
correctly super important
the design of it don't underestimate the
power of white space
to just make the resume more appealing
to the reader
but the other really important thing is
to make sure that it's customized for
that job and so
our resume writers here on staff can
help translate for instance if you've
had previous experience in hospitality
and you want to get into a construction
career we can help translate that
experience into some project management
team collaboration even reading reports
and measurements
so also the words you use in your resume
matter and you can also take some words
from maybe a job listing and incorporate
that somehow on your resume
exactly that's what's really important
is to make sure that that
resume resonates with the hiring person
speaking of hiring you guys have a
hiring event coming up on
july the 30th july 30th at our eastern
store goodwill is hosting a hiring event
doing interviews on the spot
and so people can come by they can even
come to the career center ahead of time
and get their resume
polished we'll help out with
professional clothing for that interview
day
and uh wait a minute clothing
professional clothing so sometimes
um job seekers don't especially during
this pandemic they don't have the right
clothing for an interview and so we can
help make sure that that happens
awesome thanks for your time so we'll be
talking a little bit more about that
still ahead in about 30 minutes from now
for now reporting live hector mejia 8
news now back to you guys